we can start recording so usually we
uh we do it once you start your talk but
we can actually start now just in case
we forget okay yeah but i think both me
and uh
alex is recording
yes just make me yes you can yeah brian
you can also record too that's maybe
you're because your audio maybe it's
even better so
yeah it might be yeah
my fancy podcast audio
um
are you guys mostly in person there or
do you guys have
restrictions still
uh most of us are not yet back actually
because uh the
policy yeah
i got it
but the essential experimentalist
or preservers i think they're back
oh cool
that's good
uh for san diego
as long as you submit the
vaccination proof then you can return
back to office
yeah that's right yeah exactly yeah we
can be here
we've got a bunch of people teaching
with masks on and so i thought last year
was surreal we were outside in huge
tents uh but uh but now we've got
outside with masks on
unless you're eating so i i invented a
new technology which is called the
chewing gum and drinking in diet coke
all day long uh obviates me from wearing
my mask
but uh but i've yet to patent that
solution
and you die we usually go for 45 minutes
or an hour with questions
uh yeah 45 minutes and then 15 minutes
of question will be will be good but
yeah you can see because maybe there's
already will be some oh actually so when
people ask you a question can they
uh interrupt you during the talk or are
you oh sure yeah
okay cool
people came up
yeah hi gordon
oh hey brian good to see you yeah i told
you i'd make it finally but
i'm glad we're finally here it's under
compromised circumstances yes that just
means you owe me a you know some some
pizza and some some buffalo burgers when
i come out to visit
i've got all the chewing gum and diet
coke you can consume
be careful you don't know how much i can
consume
all right i'll start sharing my slides
here
actually
and we can start in
one minute yeah okay yeah perfect
you see it you die
yep that's good okay great
let me also get you
okay i think we can start
so we're very happy to have a brian
um professor brian keating from
university of san diego
and here's
so giving us a very exciting talk so
here's the introduction of brian so
brian is
the chancellor's distinguished professor
of physics as used at ucsd
and the host of the into the impossible
podcast
he is also author of more than 200
scientific publications two u.s patents
and the best selling memoir that is
losing the nobel prize
and also
and brian received his bachelor's degree
from cash western reserve university in
1993
and his phd from brown university in
2000
later he was a postdoc fellow at denver
and caltech
and in 2007
he received a presidential early career
award for scientists and engineers
for inventing the bicep telescope
and kitting was elected fellow of the
american basic society in 2016 and is
principal investigator of the simon's
observatory in chile
and he's a commercial pilot oh wow with
multi
indian instrument ratings and is an
honorary lifetime member of the national
society of black physicists yeah thanks
brian please take over
yeah it's a pleasure to be here or be
here not there i'd rather be there
the weather today is quite atrocious if
you can believe it in san diego i always
say the easiest job in the world is san
diego meteorologist and the hardest job
as san diego sportscaster the only team
thanks to your cubs to never win a major
city to never win any kind of
professional sports
uh
championship uh especially in baseball
my beloved padres were eliminated but
they were only eliminated in the last
week of uh of the season which is pretty
impressive normally they're eliminated
uh you know opening day so it is a
pleasure to be here i did want to talk
about something that you may not be as
familiar with if you follow
cmb field experimental observational
theoretical
of which fermilab and the chicagoland
area is of course a major
contributor to and player in but this is
kind of a differential aspect that i
want to bring to people's attention in
hopes that i can get you know brilliant
people like you dai and and others my
friends dan and uh and the wonderful
folks you have out there uh to maybe
turn their considerable intellects uh my
our way here and this is to look for
violations of fundamental symmetries in
the in the cosmos not using
laboratory or you know solar system
tests but actually using the longest
optical path links possible
to reveal
perhaps violations of the most
sacrosanct laws of nature that we hold
so dearly so thanks again udai for
inviting me and gordon uh for so many
years uh
in the in the works and uh and also my
friend dan uh for being such a good
friend of mine in my show uh so yeah
please do subscribe i only have a couple
of prices of admission luckily uh one's
free and one's 99 cents uh that is my
new book comes out tomorrow think like a
nobel prize winner
based on the nine interviews i did with
nobel laureates uh ranging from sheldon
glashow to ray weiss to
um barry barrish who actually wrote the
forward and if you take a picture of
that qr code it'll whisk you away to
amazon where you can buy the kindle
version for just a mere 99 cents uh for
one week only
and uh that's because you know i already
made so much money for my first book
that i really don't need now i i didn't
nobody writes a popular science book as
dan can attest to become a
multi-millionaire so i wanted to get
this into as many young people in stem
because it's really a way to turn the
lessons not the not the knowledge of
these nobel prize winners we we can
learn that from their nobel citations
and what have you but actually their
wisdom i think is more valuable and so
this distills them into the soft skills
that we often neglect when we're
teaching our students or post-docs
advising people
in stem and these wonderful laureates
provided me a great deal of wisdom which
i hope you'll enjoy so yes 99 cents only
remind you at the end and
some custom illustrations i had made up
for the book i have a new podcast by the
same name called think like a nobel
prize winner get that wherever podcasts
are sold that's actually out now so you
can get the whole book for free
effectively
if you don't can't afford that 99 cents
i know times are tough but hopefully you
guys will do that a favor because i want
to get into as many people's minds as
possible
and then the other one is free strictly
free and that's the end of the
impossible podcast my channel on youtube
where i host these nine nobel laureates
i actually have uh 10 and 11 and 12
queued up uh coming in the next few
months and we even had your very own uh
dr dan hooper who came on this past
spring i've had on many people uh from
michio kaku neil degrasse tyson all the
way to juan maldosena
and uh hoping to get uh gerard
hoofed and many more uh luminaries as
well as folks like jill tarter and
others so yeah please do subscribe join
hit different bells not the nobel but
hit the actual bell there's dan and me
chatting back g minus two which is very
exciting and uh i salute uh all those
who do outreach to the public who pay
our salaries after all any of us who
receive
government funding certainly especially
those of us who are professors at public
universities as i said i'm going to talk
very briefly about the headline that
most people hear about when they hear
about the cmb and its b mode
polarization which is potential
constraints on inflation of which i will
provide a new insight or a new result
that's coming soon to the archive and
prl
hopefully in the week or so and uh and
that's from bicep array uh but and a
bicep and keck team rather and and but
i'm going to spend most of my time not
talking about bmotes not talking about
inflation something i find particularly
startling interesting and and perhaps
revealing of violations that we as
physicists hold sacrosanct relative to
uh neuters theorem and fundamental
conservation laws and if those were to
be manifestly violated there'd be a
concomitant breakage in the
underpinnings of all of physical law in
a way that i think would have a twofold
benefit one that would provide full
employment for theorists
for all eternity but i would also
provide a glimpse into perhaps maybe our
only glibs into you know so-called
physics beyond the standard model in
ways that we could test
uh for a quantum theory of gravity so i
think it's really exciting and then i'm
an experimentalist so i want to talk
about my uh beloved experiment the
simon's observatory which i'm privileged
to
be the foundation's uh
pi of and we have many many uh cool
things in store with that observatory
coming online in less than two years
and i want to talk especially about some
of the most pernicious effects that we
as physicists deal with which are
primarily in the domain of systematic
effects and actually the ability to use
drones to solve these vast cosmic
puzzles and again you die mentioned it
uh but but p please do feel free to you
know raise your hand just so i can see
it and then you die if you can and uh
alert me if anyone has a question or you
can just unmute that would be great
um so who was the first moral relativist
well i think the first relativist in
history i don't know if he was a moral
relativist he's certainly a fascinating
character and actually my next book is
an audiobook and it's with carlo rivelli
uh fabiola giannatti
uh jim gates and frank wilczak and my
friend lucio picarillo and it's the
first audio book ever done for galileo
galilei's works and this one's the
dialogue
which he discusses this very scenario
which is shown here where he's on a boat
and he's talking about fishes and what
would happen if the boat's being blown
and you drop a heavy object and or you
uh you know you see fish swimming and or
you see flies buzzing about inside the
cabin
as the boat moves at some speed how
would they behave and this is the first
instantiation of a concept of relativity
and it comes from the dialogue and i'm
very privileged to to announce that that
book hopefully audiobook only the
printed book has been out for some 400
years almost but the dialogue uh the
most famous book in history in fact uh
kind of transcends science itself as
albert einstein said in his form it's
the most important book ever written
and uh that i had frank wilcek the honor
of having frank wilcheck read the
forward written by albert einstein about
galileo
which is quite astounding
so um so the concept of relativity is
old and yet we still want to test it we
don't ever take the opinion of
authorities
and certainly galileo was an authority
but of course he was superseded in many
ways by albert einstein and einstein
talks a little bit about that in the
forward to that magnificent book
so the question of whether or not the uh
the earth occupies some privileged
status or motion is absolute motion is
detectable absolute position are there
absolute four vectors that's the way i
like to think about it are there
absolute four vectors are there absolute
frames of reference in the universe and
you dimensioned i went to case western
not far from where you guys are
in beautiful cleveland ohio
and we uh we had the honor and the
privilege of having uh that experiment
the michelson-morley experiment who
after galileo's relativistic experiment
still didn't take the maestro's word for
it and they decided to test for their
movement with respect to the aether and
uh there's an image of the apparatus
which is not far from uh from where you
guys are in the basement of uh of the um
you know physics department
at the shankland auditorium and so forth
at case western where i did my
undergraduate
and this experiment uh was really
is considered in many ways the most
important quote unquote failed
experiment uh because it failed to
detect this effect and uh i like to
think of it as you know kind of maybe
putting a little bit of the uh giving a
little bit of of a back reaction if you
will to karl popper and others you know
who who talk about the the the prospects
for experimental testability as the
cinequan non of science and even i like
to point out even popper was a huge
supporter of the steady state universe
which kind of maintained what was known
as the perfect cosmological principle in
other words the cosmological principle
states that the universe is on large
scales isotropic and homogeneous and
they said well einstein
you know connected this to a notion of
space and time unified together so
really you shouldn't expect there to be
a time translation asymmetry in time
either and therefore the big bang would
maximally violate that symmetry and so
they and others tommy gold and and and
others supported a notion of an eternal
universe slowly oscillating and cycling
and these models are actually still in
vogue my friend paul steinhardt writing
me early this morning about some new
discoveries in in his preferred model
the bouncing cosmological model
i have a video on my channel about sir
roger penrose's conformal cyclic
cosmology and how we could falsify that
and what the virtues are of having a
model of cosmology that has no
singularities within it and i think
those are fascinating to consider
singularities give cosmologists a lot of
grief
and um and may not be
physically realizable in our universe so
it pays to kind of consider alternatives
so uh for many years we've tested the
notion of relativity and not taken it
for granted and the question still
remains to this very day are we totally
sure there isn't a preferred 4 vector in
the cosmos a preferred system position
for momentum
or for position that indicates a
preferred frame
and we aim to test that in ways that i
plan to explicate now
before i do that it is legally incumbent
upon me to describe the progress that
we've made in experimental cosmology
since the 1960s
when the first serendipitous discovery
the cmb was made
in new jersey at holmdale uh new jersey
uh which formerly known as bell
laboratories now known as a nokia
and it's quite a special place to go and
visit it's part of historic
monuments as as i know uh i believe the
wilson building is there uh and it's a
it's done so for for great purpose
because it was really there that we
started to launch one of the most
precise and accurate probes of cosmic
history and in doing so we've learned a
great deal about the universe from
ground balloon and spaceborne
instrumentation
including the detection of e-mode
polarization including the claim
detection of b-mode polarization and
actually the actual detection of lens b
mode polarization which is where the
cmb's e-mode gets gravitationally lensed
and warped and twisted into a b mode
polarization but of course we all know
some of us more than others
about the
the retracted or not confirmed
contradicted the results of bicep two
and i'll talk a little bit about that in
just a bit uh and that was to detect
possibly the quantum fluctuations
leading to primordial b mode
polarization
and if that were uh or held up and
verified which it was not
that would have been seen as the
strongest possible evidence that one
could get at least at present for an
inflationary cosmogenesis event at an
inflation-like event near to the big
bang itself
and so i think it's fascinating that
we're we're rightfully concerned with
making these detections and as you may
know in the chicagoland area uh the uh
s4 cmb stage 4 experiment is preceding a
pace uh with proposals and and white
papers in the decadal survey is
hopefully going to be out any time uh
this this moment could come out during
this talk
and we have a expansion plans for the
simon's observatory as well and these
are billion dollar class experiments in
the case of cmb stage four hundred
hundred million dollars in the case of
the simon's observatory fully funded um
and uh and i think it's it's fascinating
so much attention rightfully so to these
origin events in the universe and we
kind of got a glimpse of that early on
in cosmology or seven years ago this
year with the bicep two event which i'll
hearken back to in a bit
but if you had microwave eyes uh this is
what you'd see
over the simon's array which is now
operating in the atacama desert of chile
adjacent to the to the class experiment
and to the atacama cosmology telescope
act experiment and to the future site of
the simon's observatory and i'll show
you some construction pictures of that
experiment now if you could take away
the monopole 2.72 kelvin signal you'd be
left with this fluctuation pattern if
you had appropriate contrast
and you could even start to distinguish
polarization signals if you happen to
have a couple of
polarizers nearby and you could twist
and orient them uh connected to your
very high sensitivity detectors
and if you do so you can decompose the
pattern of microwave polarization into
an e-mode pattern and a b-mode pattern
and you see here some cartoons from
kamiankowski and ellie kovetz paper from
2015 annual reviews
and you see from the bicep2 our artwork
there um the kind of types of physics
that are responsible for both e-mode
polarization which has been detected
since the daisy experiment 2002
and b mode polarization of a primordial
type as i say we've detected the lensing
of the top panel um a we've detected
that acquiring a tiny a bit of uh of b
mode type characters swirling twisting
parity asymmetric polarization we've
detected that that's caused not by
primordial forces but by dark matter
operating in the intermediate universe
say peaking at a redshift of one or two
or maybe slightly higher but certainly
not primordial at redshifts of thousands
or millions even as we could hope to
probe
with the cmb b mode polarization at
large angular scales
and that's where a lot of the interest
lies in the constraints on inflation
that a b mode mission c and b stage four
simon's observatory simon zoray etc
could provide
in 2014 as i mentioned we announced the
discovery of a signal now this signal on
the lower panel the b mode signal this
is from updated data i'll say more about
that in just a second
you see the phenomenal level of
precision that we're getting to we're
getting to 300 nano kelvin level
polarization or 100 nano kelvin level
signals uh in polarization and i i
remind you your eye is actually slightly
polarization sensitive the macula has a
pigment
which is slightly polarization but
there's no no very few humans that i'm
aware of can detect the polarization of
even the atmosphere which is actually
highly polarized compared to the cmb's
beam mode polarization at parts per
billion remember this is a fraction of
2.7 kelvin we're hoping to get down to
the parts per billion few parts per
billion of that signal just phenomenal
you could not have predicted it if you
told penzias and wilson different wilson
than the wilson uh that you guys are
affiliated with but if you told pensions
and wilson in 1965 um
gordon moore is going to come along in
four years and come up with an eponymous
law
moore's law um and that cmb detectors
will double every two years and their or
maybe even every year in their
sensitivity they would not have expected
that you could detect levels of signal
that we are routinely detecting with the
instruments observing today after uh 50
56 years elapsed time it's just
astounding
now of course this made a huge headline
we announced it as ripples from the big
bang uh etc and uh we all
as i say some of us more than others
this is on cnn and others if i was
giving a talk on inflation i'd keep
going on this theme but i want to get to
the other topics today but i will point
out that we do have a constraint paper
the bicep team rather has a constrained
paper that's coming out very soon the
abstract for which is on the web
and prl it's been accepted back in
august and it should come out in the
next few days so the constraint is uh
extremely exquisitely tight it's three
percent tensor to scalar ratio and again
i'm not going to get into that i could
come when i come and visit uh for some
deep dish diet coke and gum i will
certainly be happy to talk about all the
progress we've made in this field
hopefully even more so when the bicep
array the successor to bicep keck
comes online as well as the uh as well
as the simon's observatory and simon's
array instruments
of course we know what happened in my
book i
explained in excruciating detail what
happened with uh the original
announcement in 2012. now you notice
there's an upper limit at two sigma
upper limit effectively of of less than
3.5
3.6 percent
and that's exquisitely constraining and
something i never thought would be
possible when i proposed to build bicep
back in 2001
exactly 20 years ago today
and uh and it's just astounding because
the progress is it's come at great cost
literally figuratively etc and it's just
amazing that this team has done
spectacularly well at constraining
inflationary models but of course there
is no one inflationary model
you give a theorists enough coffee and
they can come up with as many as you
like but in the context of the types of
models i'm talking about in just a
minute
there are sort of uh
asymmetries that can be detected that in
some sense are even more interesting
than the inflationary signals that we
kind of all expect right i mean we would
be very surprised and in fact almost all
the alternatives to inflation that i
mentioned namely uh the conformal cyclic
model of sir roger penrose or paul
steinhardt and aegis is bouncing models
or
robert brandenburger cameron baffa
string gas cosmology they all feature
some
some vestiges i would say of an
inflationary model where they have
scalar fields um they actually have
inflation built into them say
uh or they
have to predict things that we don't
believe in
having evidence for at least at this
moment error bonds et cetera et cetera
so there are difficulties with all the
alternatives as well don't get me wrong
um but if we discover either one of
those four different alternatives
correct to inflation they they aren't as
dissimilar to inflation as one would
naively think by hearing the word
alternatives so um it's quite expected
that inflation is at least correct for
uh some version of it for providing
seeds of cosmic structure and i think
that's the most successful way to think
about it not think about it as a seed of
cosmogenesis i think that's incorrect um
but uh what i want to talk about now is
not the death knell what happened
afterwards when we discovered that our
signal was attributable to dust and that
was done in com concert with the planck
team
i'm not going to talk much more about
inflation except to say that we are
chastened and hardened by these results
and we now know that one must as we did
know back then i shouldn't say it as if
it's a new uh found discovery that we
have to look for all systematic effects
even those that are astrophysical but
not cosmological such as dust and so we
build into our instruments as i'll
discuss in a bit we'll build
in the capability to measure cosmic dust
as well heating that great
experimentalist mahatma gandhi um
nominated the same number of times for
the nobel prize as adolf hitler uh never
won it though neither one of them won it
um he said that seeker after truth
should be humbler than the dust the
world crushes the dust under its feet
but only the seeker after truth should
so humble himself that even the dust
could crush him
only then and not until then will he
have a glimpse of truth so we have to be
humble when we approach the cosmos that
includes building in the capabilities to
measure cosmic dust as well and it will
turn out that dust is much much less
pernicious in searches for these moving
violations that i'm about to discuss
so let's talk about birefringence first
what is birefringence it means double
refraction
it was first observed in the 1600s and
and this effect is illustrated by a
piece of icelandic spar calcite which
shows two different images because the
the ink say that's producing the the
words calcite and the line uh those are
propagating through an an asymmetric
crystal crystal that's not uh amorphous
it's not like glass and it's not a
crystal that has cubic structure either
it has this orthorhombic structure
which then gives it two different
indices of refraction so horizontal and
vertical light propagate at different
speeds as if there's two different
indices like your glasses
with such a material would look quite uh
confusing to you life would look even
more confusing than it already does and
you can suppress one of those with a
polarizer and i have a video coming up
about that
but the
the phenomenon was not really understood
until fresnel famous fresnel and robert
young and the wave theory of light it
did give a lot of credibility to the
wave theory of light and actually is
only interpretable as a uh as a
byproduct of light of the
electromagnetic radiation that we call
light having a transverse character and
that was one of the first instantiations
of that so i think it's very cool this
goes back 400 years almost uh this
phenomenon and uh and yet now we're
planning to look for it not in our
you know chunks of rocks found in
iceland but in the universe at large and
has an even cuter connection
to the projects that i work on um here's
uh kind of a distillation of this from
greg gabadzi he's a friend and associate
director of physical sciences at simon's
foundation and you see in the lower
right that's jim simons talking about
what is a churn simon's three form it's
the same churn simon's the same simon's
rather uh ss turns uh sadly is no longer
with us
but they worked out a purely topological
invariant um that is a three form and
it's uh unlike almost any other kind of
mechanism in physics but this can
actually endow
in a way that i'll describe and can
endow light
potentially with a type of uh with a
type of
birefringent character that could be
detected only on the largest cosmic
scales
and i think it's just fascinating and
again it tickles me that's the same jim
simons as is uh responsible for
supporting uh almost uh you know ninety
percent of the cost of the simon's
observatory and uh and the simon's array
so it's quite astounding uh this this
man jim simons has had wonderful careers
and contributions in three different
fields at the highest levels from
mathematics where he was chair at stony
brook for many years the philanthropy
and obviously in the hedge fund world
so
this type of three form when the proper
derivatives can be obtained you see
there's a there's a preferred uh three
vector component of a p mu p mu
which then can break lorenz and variance
symmetry and then manifest it will also
break parity symmetry in a way i'll
describe
so what would lorenz invariance
violation mean it would mean many of us
would either be fully employed or
unemployed because it would mean that
the standard model
is based on sort of a shaky foundation
that i'll analogize in just a second
but the built into both gr and the
standard model of particle physics is
lorentz symmetry uh invariance under
boost no preferred reference frames i
like to say the universe doesn't care
about where you are who you are what you
are
the laws of physics according to lorentz
are uh are symmetric
um and
and yet if we believe that eventually we
could unify gr with quantum field theory
i.e make it part of the standard model
as is the holy grail for folks ranging
from einstein uh to uh to frank wilcek
and juan maldacena and many other people
that have uh honored me on the show uh
nevertheless i think it's quite
fascinating that if you
violate lorenz symmetry in a convincing
way it could point us in a in a way to
new insights at least into
quantum gravity
so this slide from my friend at uh cal
poly
san luis obispo
matt muse and he makes this little
cartoon that shows everything in physics
that we teach to our undergraduates uh
built on these bricks and these blocks
that my kids like to knock down
but the three pillars are quantum
mechanics yeah the curved space time of
of gr
and loren symmetry and if there is a
theory of everything of course there's
no guarantee there is a theory of
everything but if there is would there
not be a shift an observable shift
downstream
um if lorenz symmetry was not an exact
symmetry as we assume it to be
and it's not so crazy to think about
that because we know that there are
symmetries once held to be sacrosanct
such as parity and charge invariance
discrete symmetries that are known to be
broken in not only in
in
in the standard model but also in uh in
things ranging as diverse from uh the
origin of life and prebiotic chemistry
as i say
uh to to our own bodies etc so parity
invariance is broken and it is a
well-known fact of nature predicted as
i'll show here
in um
in the 1950s theoretically predicted and
this is really astounding because i
think this led to as you guys are much
more expert than i those of you traffic
and particle accelerators that uh these
decays were found to
be
quite quite uh asymmetric under uh
certain types of uh discrete symmetry uh
invariances and that
was then thought to that these parity
violations were held to be true
the invariance rather was held to be a
component of the then standard model in
the 50s and it was sort of theoretically
predicted uh based on data from these uh
from these experiments that were built
in in instruments like brookhaven uh and
other places
and i think it's quite fascinating
because very soon after this paper the
question of parody conservation was
published in a physical review
only about
a few months later was this actually uh
tested and it was tested at uh at
columbia at the laboratory in colombia
and also the national bureau of
standards now called nist
by uh chiang san wu madam wu
and this was done she did it over
christmas uh 1956
and then they submitted the paper two
weeks later
it's it's really an astounding thing and
i asked my friends on followers on
twitter you know what's the most
important experiment ever done and many
people put up this experiment the famous
matamu experiment that have revealed
that cobalt nuclei as viewed in a mirror
exhibited this anisotropic emission just
the same way as if you reverse the
direction of spin and that shouldn't
hold true if parity was maintained if cp
was maintained
and this involved an incredible
incredible tour de force
of experimental
technology back in the 1950s i mean we
have dilution refrigerators etc here uh
as part of the simon's observatory and
we bought them
and they only get us to six millikelvin
and to get down to three millikelvin and
do this and observe also this as a
particle experiment and and do so you
know over 60 years ago it's just
astounding and do this in weeks a month
you know just a few weeks after the
paper and just and submit it and and
have it detected obviously with such
high confidence and it was confirmed
months later by letterman and and others
you can um probably and i do have
another video about that coming soon as
well
unfortunately this did win nobel prizes
uh for lee and yang uh who's just
celebrated his 99th birthday i believe
yesterday
and uh so they won nobel prizes and and
that was that was nice um but uh but
madame wu she just got a stamp and
that's unfortunate
uh this year she was honored with a
forever stamp i mean it's it's good that
she got a stamp uh but many think she
deserved her share of the nobel prize
so how could you measure cp violation
uh you can do so using what we call
cosmic polarization rotation
cpr
and you see this picture from moving
violation that i once got but you see
the initials on the police cars in new
york city there cpr i think that's
pretty cool
so uh what could you do with a violation
like this well sean carroll in 1990 and
his uh and uh roman jakiev and george
field they wrote a apocal paper which is
still cited many hundreds of times a
year
and this paper really worked through as
a worked example what would happen if
you added to the maxwell lagrangian if
you added this three form this four
momentum that p mu that i said before
now it's pa
um coupled to the uh electromagnetic
potential and the maxwell tensor and if
you couple those together and just go
through
and grind out maxwell's equations
from those and then you substitute in
and obtain the wave equation you'll find
there's a dispersive wave equation
and the wave equation is dispersive in
that it has a slight preference for left
circular polarization versus right
and sean and others explained that in
1990
and this has a net effect of rotating
the plane of linear polarization after
traversing some distance through uh the
universe exactly as light passing
through a crystal calcite crystal
rotates the plane of polarization as
well in fact you can suppress one of the
two polarization states with a piece of
of linear polarizing material
and the effect is illustrated here as i
show uh so starting on the left you have
the electromagnetic field the
polarization vector classified by the
electric field direction
that determines the polarization state
starts off purely vertically traverses
some distance of optically active
calcite and emerges rotated by 45
degrees and it'll rotate more if the
calcite is longer and if the
birefringent term the optical activity
uh is larger and it's actually very very
slight so you need decent thicknesses
unless you have
materials like calcite and crystalline
quartz and we actually use that property
of of materials especially sapphire and
synthetic sapphire
aluminum oxide and uh we don't use
calcite for microwave uh telescopes but
you you could and it would rotate the
plane of polarization we use that to
create half wave plate polarization
modulators because you only want to
modulate the signal that you're
interested in detecting because very
faint and the background is unpolarized
largely even though it's billion times
brighter it can remain unmodulated and
you lock in phase instead of detect
dickey switching on the polarization
signal and so you can rotate this this
block of orange material here and you
rotate that at some rate and the
polarization will rotate at twice that
rate because polarization um
has this unidirectional spin one
character
so you look for a perfection uh
preferred direction in space-time and i
always joke that you know um that this
has actually been found already it was
predicted in the cosmological context by
uh your friend not too far from where
you guys are mike turner
uh and his student woodrow i believe and
that was 1988 they wrote down this again
whenever you see
maxwell type tensor with itself
contracted on with itself times a a four
vector
like ga
or the comp the three components of a
four vector that you can actually expect
some kind of optical activity and the
amount of rotation beta will be the
path length which in for photons is just
the time of observation
uh
subtracted from the time of emission
times the speed of light and you'll get
a rotation this phi dot theta dot and
you can go through the math yourself
it's actually a really exquisite paper
and this was claimed to be detected
multiple times in cosmology
um and so here's the original paper i
showed you that where sean and george
and roman work through this
and they come out with this chern simons
i like to point out that it was
published on february 15th which all of
us galileo aficionados know it was his
birthday uh galileo's birthday um and
then they go through the math and they
come up with the electromagnetic
contribution and sure and simon's term
and that kind of rotation and they talk
about ways that you could discover it in
in topological masses
uh gauge fields etc but this is the
first application to cosmology
and astronomy
so um recently as i said in the abstract
there was a claim detection of this
effect or evidence or a hint for it or
the attentive there's a lot of provisos
okay uh so my friend ichiro komatsu
and myanma uh miami who's a collaborator
on polar bear
which i also i'm affiliated with uh they
claimed a hints
of the uh nature potentially of dark
energy because a preferred direction
purely one in time would result in an
isotropic rotation of polarization all
about the same axis all in the same
preferred handedness
and the amount of optical activity the
amount of rotation would be proportional
to the optical path length and that's
proportional to the time of emission as
i said subtracted from the time of
observation and so miami and others say
that this could actually be related to
quintessence
quintessence being a derivative in some
sense of the dark energy
of dark energy's properties over cosmic
time and this would sort of sample that
that dark energy evolution at different
times from the uh from the earliest time
to today and actually you could see it
and sample it versus redshift and some
work that i've done with collaborators
using quasar polarization you might be
able to get actual samples of the
derivative of this term and that that's
a talk for another day uh but it'll be
interesting because we all assume that
you know that perhaps dark energy is a
cosmological constant but how do we know
again this would provide a breakage of
and variance symmetry if you like with
respect to time it would say there
really is uh some sort of preferred
frame and maybe we're in it right now
some find that very likely unlikely
and so this got a lot of attention it
kind of reminded me a little bit of the
bicep 2 result and so this is the thing
i talk about they use the plank
satellite data and they go through this
um they go through this this
characterization citing sean carroll and
turner woodrow's paper would just paper
and they come up with a plausible you
know sort of hints below three sigma by
far but still interesting and perhaps
probative but as i said
i believe that this type of phenomena is
almost time translation invariant in the
sense that it seems to come up every
decade or two
that people uh discover a detection of
this effect and you see here another you
know this is from 1997.
you see here some people that are still
in the news today there's like newt
gingrich you still hear about him you
hear about benjamin netanyahu there he
is on the left
but like that you find out a
an interesting
headline in the lower right and says
this side up may apply to the universe
after all
and this was a claim detection from
radial galaxies intermediate redshift
that they had a preferred uh
polarization
uh property distribution that
polarization effectively was
birefringent there was an uh what's
called an ordinary axis as in the
crystal calcite and an extraordinary
axis so radio waves coming at different
angles uh from different polarized uh
sources in the intermediate redshift
universe
would uh would actually
cause different amounts of radiation to
be polarized depending on how far uh
they've come from and depending on what
polarization you're measuring so they go
through here and i love another one um
actually another quote that's time
translation and variant from our friend
jim peebles in the lower left he says it
would really be a profound change in
physics if it is true
and you hear that a lot actually i heard
that from ichiro kamatsu quoting uh jim
peebles in the announcement made in 2020
so you're talking about uh you know 23
years after this
paper was written and actually this
result was only
unsubstantiated disconfirmed
due to an analysis by sean carroll
who you would think would have wanted
this effect to be true more than any
other person and yet he found they had
made a huge statistical error in the
analysis basically a real blunder in
this case it wasn't it wasn't like a
systematic error they misinterpreted the
the way that radio polarizations are
reported and so it was they didn't
recognize that
a zero degree polarization angle is the
same to an astronomer as a 180 degree
polarization state and they would count
those differently and then when you
added up zero and 180 or uh you know
minus 180 and plus 180 you would get you
get the same you get a result which when
average would go to 90 degrees which is
what they're showing in the upper right
plot that things at right angles to each
other were
producing similar types of behaviors
which would be forbidden if the standard
model was perfectly the rents symmetric
but anyway so this is saying
that the universe has a birefringent
property to it and then about 10 years
after that 2009 or so we had another
paper that came out that said probing
cpt violation basically claiming a three
plus sigma detection
of cpt violation
and concomitant lorenz invariance you
see the churn simon's term at the top of
the abstract using bicep data and quad
data and this we later invalidated
primarily through
the propagation of errors where they
basically treated all these experiments
separately
as if they were completely independently
even though many of them were measuring
the exact same signals and fundamentally
we have built-in calibration
uncertainties that really wreck the
precision
wreck the accuracy of these results and
so you can get very high precision but
the accuracy is compromised in a way
that i'll explain and i hope that we'll
improve upon
so what did the 2020 result say again it
showed a
basically 2.4 sigma level exclusion
of birefringence which is equivalent to
99.2 percent it always sounds better in
percent uh then in sigma and you know as
my late great colleague hans parr said
you know at three sigma they'll they'll
invite you to give a seminar by zoom uh
but you know at five sigma they invite
you to sweden and so it's not really key
you know if we should really be paying
too much attention to a 2.4 sigma result
and nevertheless i think it shows and
and portrays rightly so the interest
that we have in probing lorenz and
variants etc with telescopes like this
so here's a compilation that one of my
students made a couple of years ago and
i added on the miami and komatsu results
so these are all the cmb experiments in
red or radio and ultraviolet
measurements ignore those but almost all
the cmb experiments were consistent with
a less than zero cosmic polarization
rotation
and as i say the game changing nature
could only occur if the uh result can be
confirmed and uh and so far we are still
working on this so i already talked
about e modes and b modes for these
signals we look for so-called forbidden
correlations correlations that should
not exist unless there is a tiny and it
has to be tiny we know in from solar
system probes that this effect can't be
very big
we know from cmb observations that this
result must be at sort of the sub degree
of rotation a few arc minutes at most
and yet we believe that will be
eminently measurable by upcoming
instruments like simon's ray and and
like and like the simon's observatory
that i'll talk about
so the simon's observatory was uh funded
about five years ago we're almost done
with construction of the project it
comprises four telescopes three small
aperture telescopes designed to go after
primordial b modes here's the site
this is a different view as before
looking now um to the southwest
and it shows the atacama top cosmology
telescope class and the simon's array in
the foreground
we did a groundbreaking two years ago
with jim and marilyn simons they're on
the right so i put
the 26th richest person in the world to
work uh shoveling dirt at uh 17 000 feet
i can add that to my cv
there's adrian lee on the left and the
current president of the simon's
foundation david spurgle and orange
marilyn and jim have finally retired
from uh those positions but they're
still hard at work as always
so our main targets for the cmb projects
on simon's observatory to measure
primordial b modes lensing clusters
e-modes et cetera et cetera but i want
to talk about um
i want to here's a collaboration on our
last face-to-face meeting we hope we'll
have one here in san diego next
in july of 2022 finally
it's been too long
and so it's a huge team about 300
scientists 45 institutions every
continent on the planet including
antarctica
and this is a fascinating instrument
that here's the location here that we
have to build from scratch there's no
support here we have to truck up our own
concrete or on diesel fuel you know
here's some concrete being poured for
one of the platforms for the small
telescopes
this is back in march
um so we're finally getting over covered
and chile's done quite well but still
there's shutdowns but we have to do
everything ourselves this is that 17 200
feet above sea level 5200 meters
what are we building as i said a huge
telescope a six meter diameter large
aperture telescope and three small
aperture telescopes one of which is in
the high bay directly across from my
window here at uc san diego
and we'll have six frequencies as shown
here and that's to mitigate against dust
and synchrotron radiation masquerading
as primordial b mode polarization
they're enclosed these huge telescopes
are not huge these are actually small
they're about 50 bigger than the
original bicep 2 instrument
and aperture and but they're refracting
telescopes just like galileo and just
like bicep two these are very simple
instruments the cleanest optical system
you can possibly implement then they
have to be surrounded by these large
ground screens and then there's a large
telescope which is fast you know in in
the biggest cmb instrument ever devised
physically it's 2.3 meters in diameter
so you can have five graduate students
you know kind of arranged inside at a
time
and uh comfortably not violating coveted
restrictions and these are cooled to
about 0.1 kelvin using dilution
refrigerator dr gas
system using helium-3 helium-4
and we
and we install these and here's just the
ones at ucsd the only ones i can take
pictures of uh so here we are with the
telescope that's an actual telescope the
white object is the cross stat it gets
uh it gets its detectors made by suzanne
stags's team at princeton uh and nist
and slack and then we integrate them all
together and the detectors are
phenomenal and i would encourage you to
have suzanne speak about how these
wonderful detectors of hers work
really the beating heart of these
instruments and we get uh we believe
that they'll be the both the most
sensitive individual detectors but also
the most sensitive arrays of instruments
these are going to be deployed as i say
starting in early 2023 we believe we
will get first science observations
including probes of cmb polarization
violation
uh lorenzen variance violation
and then we'll be observing with the
large telescope again mark devlin is
leading that you should invite him to
give a talk about the led science which
is so fascinating
but what is the bugaboo it's systematic
errors how do we get rid of systematic
errors well the best hope for getting
rid of systematic errors is actually to
build our own calibration sources
because there are no
actual i'm going to skip over this but
if you miscalibrate your detector by
some rotated amount that you're ignorant
of you will get a b mode exactly a
hundred percent conversion of e modes
which we know exists for two decades now
and a lens can rotate completely into a
b mode and it'll produce 100
correlation of the forbidden variety
that is indicative of these lorentz and
variance violations so to be very
careful about that
and so these signals get uh quite hard
to uh to get rid of and actually it's
much harder to calibrate a signal for
measuring this this birefringent signal
than even calibrating for the
inflationary b mode signal because bb
goes as the systematic error term omega
squared or as say the tb term that we
would look for as a probe of the
evidence for a lorentzian variation
violating signal only goes linearly with
this small and these are small numbers
so omega squared is completely
negligible but omega is not and so we
have to be careful about that and so one
of our colleagues uh rolanda dunner at
um uh is a physical professor at
pontifica university in chile he's
gotten funded for a drone i promised you
drones and i don't want to let you down
so he's built this drone system and has
now gotten a very large got 250 million
a chilean pesos but that's a lot of
money it's still a lot of money uh and
he can actually do better by far than
the planck satellite which was
responsible for uh providing the limits
that have become so provocative in this
field and he sent me a video this is a
site so he does very precise
photogrammetry of our site and he tests
it out and he's going to be building a
source because there are no natural
sources of 100 understood microwave
polarization and that's what you need to
calibrate to make an accurate
measurement
so um so here he is flying his drone um
i think it'd be cool to deliver um you
know some visca sandwiches these are
these little rodents that live up there
but uh but anyway this is a phenomenal
instrument that he's building with his
team and here's one of his uh students
and one of our colleagues calibrating it
here's the flying over the system and so
it's from this vantage point he can park
and station keep and spray 100 percent
known polarization signals into that
telescope that's the atacama cosmology
telescope and then that can be scanned
you see the telescope moving and again
extremely accurate calibration of your
signals and that's what's needed to get
below and confirm or refute the results
of me and me and kamatsu so what's next
i'm going to conclude
this is a very fascinating subject this
is just as of a couple of years ago when
my undergraduates plotted how many
papers referenced this affect churn
simons cosmic birefringence lorenz and
variance so it started with the sean
carroll's paper i showed you before one
reference in 1990 and now there's
hundreds per year this stopped in 2014.
and it could reveal as we show here the
presence of what's known as a
as a crisis so steve weinberg late great
stephen weinberg said
that physics was short on crises even
though we thrive on crises crises but
today it's full of it and we have a lot
as mike turner often says precision
cosmology is great but accurate
cosmology is even better so we need to
do better with respect to systematics
could be astrophysical systematics it
could be instrumental systematics
can we solve concomitantly we can
measure primarily magnetic fields the
earliest magnetic fields in the universe
with the simon's observatory we have
papers about that
is a cb cosmopolitan's hint real is dark
energy constant is it like quintessence
what is dark matter made of another
allied concomitant thing we get for free
is constraints on axion-like particles
uh via their shift in the cmb's
polarization that we detect and we
measure it daily with a sensitive
instrument we can actually test for
axiom electromagnetic potential
variation
and then is lawrence and variance a
sacrosanct aspect of physics and there
you see dan down there talking about the
implications for g minus two back on my
channel so again i implore you shameless
plug
um didn't write the book to get rich but
99 cents i think most of you guys can
afford
uh and it's only that cheap for this
week so please do me the honor of that
better than winning a nobel prize for
sure distilling their knowledge and
their wisdom into life hacks for
stem professionals like ourselves
and lastly yes please do subscribe to my
youtube channel so you can take a
picture and now i will take questions
sorry i went a little over you tonight
corey thanks a lot uh yeah thank you
very much for the talk let's give a
brian a round of applause thank you very
much
and uh yeah uh please raise your hand or
directly
yourself to ask a question let me
make sure i see all the
views
together
okay
yep is there any questions
oh
yeah maybe i'll ask the question first
so
among all of these kind of
new anomalies or as you say like the the
crisis
you think is the most promising for us
to understand the universe better
well you know i think there are a lot
and you know there's there's no shortage
of them we we think it could be that
they're
you know there could be both
contributions from early dark energy say
for the hubble constant tension that's
that's come to the fore
um recently
both from uh potentially the
contribution of early dark energy maybe
being different than late dark energy
uh or it could be the injection and
that's an unknown signal but we know for
sure that magnetic fields exist in the
universe
and they could have played a much more
prominent role as colbin turner pointed
out in 1990 in the famous book
the injection of magnetic field stress
energy will produce a
a change in the einstein you know
perturbation equations and those will
produce you know b modes that could be
effectively downstream can be measured
by only sensitive uh precise and
accurate instruments
and that could uh do two things first of
all be great to have a measurement of
the earliest magnetic field in the
universe
in an in a structure that's not
gravitationally collapsed as is
currently uh measured and there's
actually a lower limit on the amount of
magnetic field energy
and that comes from a gamma ray
observatory but that that limit is that
the magnetic field the primordial
magnetic field string has to be greater
than one micro nano gauss
which is not great but seeing as the
current upper limits so we have a lower
limit and we have an upper limit from c
and b experiments that's about a nano
gauss
closing that huge 16 order magnitude 15
order magnitude gap is not going to be
easy but uh perhaps our only hope is to
use the cmb
and then we know that magnetic fields
exist so they must have started with the
very first one right there must have
been a chicken or egg there must have
been an egg at some point even if the
chicken came first so be very
interesting to me to measure i like to
measure signals that
that are known to exist and having a
lower limit as was done with neutrino
oscillations to get lower limits on mass
that's another thing we're looking for
so i think the most you know likely
solution could be primarily magnetic
fields just with the bayesian prior that
we know magnetic fields exist but none
of these other things do we know exist
thanks
hey brian can you give me an idea of
what people have in mind for the origin
of these magnetic fields like uh
i mean i know people talk about uh
topological defects and phase
transitions leading to them but like i
don't think those will lead to the kind
of magnetic fields you're talking about
can you give me a inkling of you know
what might be behind something like this
if you were to observe it
yeah i mean this is yeah it's definitely
more your bailiwick than mine but i have
heard in the context of certain
inflationary models
uh some gut models you know that that
you would have residuals it may be you
know it's a very delicate interplay you
know when you make magnetic monopoles
and when you get rid of these magnetic
monopoles and gut theories um we
obviously wouldn't observe any in our
universe if inflation took place our
observable universe
and nevertheless i think there are you
know uh expectations that at some level
they must be nucleated and there might
be as i say magnetic monopoles or domain
walls or some other uh
allied physics cosmic strings things
like that that aren't completely
outlandish
as the source of magnetic fields i again
you know it's like where did neutrinos
come from it's not uh necessarily
something i'm going to engage in
speculation about you know what caused
the origin of these things no or
inflation itself even but the downstream
effects that to have a milky way size
magnetic field you know border you know
tens of microgauss you need to start you
know there's just not enough time for
magnetic dynamo activity to take place
or cluster dynamo activity to take place
so you have to ask well was there some
seed to generate the observed levels of
magnetic fields that we see in collapse
structures so answer your question there
are there are some you know theories for
this colbin turner discuss some some
primogenitors for these for these
magnetic fields but um yeah i wouldn't
say that any of them are on really
strong footage except you know and and
for an observer's perspective you know
they just have to exist for us to
measure them
and they have to be above the threshold
of our detectability
thanks brian
yeah
thank you very much i think we have a
few last few minutes if there's some
question feel free to ask right now
and
take a look
okay i think that's all the questions
yeah thanks a lot for giving
oh actually is there a question
oh actually yeah i think there's no
question for now yeah and let's thank
brian again thank you very much
and uh yeah
we're very happy to have you and thanks
everyone for coming to the
talk yeah thanks a lot thanks guys it
was great you died take care i look
forward to seeing you here yeah thank
you very much okay bye bye
you